hi my name is Julie hi graduated in 2002
and I'm in the for-profit education
sector and last year i purchased a small
school which i changed its name to
mayfield college and our primary focus
actually is in real estate and so we're
in the process of purchasing our first
commercial building hi my name is rich
kelly and i am a principal along with my
partner Dave Carver of a small private
equity firm called search fund partners
we invest exclusively in searchers and
their acquisitions afterwards I
graduated here in 1989 and the bulk of
my career before that was in commercial
real estate and residential real estate
development hi I'm Moyes I Lumbergh I
was last night's with Julie class of o2
and my background is primarily in
private equity investing decided to
raise a search fund and try to acquire a
company I closed a deal approximately a
year ago to buy a company that manages
receivables for healthcare providers
rich is one of my investors um and I'm
just very happy to be here I'm Michael
sanabria I did not do search fun about
four and a half years ago I went out and
did my own search acquired a company it
is a commercial printing company which
for those of you are not a walk-up
business but would do manufacturing the
things such as wine labels sales
marketing material that supports brands
like Visa Fetzer behringer so the shelf
talkers and necker's things like that
you might see in your stores we bring
things like that and michael was a
classmate of mine heroes United 93 yes
um in I spent a fair amount of my time
talking about search fence which some
people can't find humorous because my
husband actually did a search fund he's
class in 95 so I've lived them
personally and I certainly love them
professionally daily in my job here at
the GSB voices enrich do you want to
talk just basically about the search for
for those who may not be familiar with
it sure i'll start with my perspective
first off to give you a little bit of
context on how deeply we've been
drinking the kool-aid we are invested in
nine ongoing companies that were
acquired through search funds and we're
currently invested in eight ongoing
searches so we are thinking living and
breathing search funds all the time the
gist of a search fund is that people
have been buying and selling businesses
for thousands of years and the search
fund is a slightly more disciplined way
of doing that that allows an
entrepreneur who envisions themselves
running a business and owning it and
controlling it a two-year window to two
and a half year window where his only
job his or her only job is to find the
right business for them most of the
businesses that get bought over time or
kind of done on a side job basis or
they're done on a full-time basis but
without specific financial backing blind
search fun kind of eliminates two of
those problems by providing financial
backing to the entrepreneur and giving
them the discipline and focus to be able
to say no to the first hundred deals
they look at because they know that
they've got quite a bit of time and a
fairly discerning investor base that is
only going to invest in a deal that
really fits the fits the rubric so we
really enjoy the search fund process we
value the two-year period whether
entrepreneur is searching that's kind of
an option period where we get to know
the entrepreneur work with them see how
they handle disappointment how they
handle negotiations see how they react
to challenges and so when they finally
bring a deal to us we're usually very
comfortable them as managers and we're
also generally pretty comfortable with
the deal because a deal takes six months
to close from the first ethic fastest
for the first time you contact the
seller to the actual closing so you you
kind of instead of a book landing on
your desk and having them three weeks to
decide whether you want to invest in
them in the industry and in the business
you've kind of got a rolling start on it
all of the searchers that we back so far
have found businesses that's one of the
highest risk points in them in the chain
evidence sort of shows that up to forty
percent of the people that do a search
fund do not find a business and all in
all we just think it's a great little
specialized asset nation what is this
you're a detective from perspective yeah
searcher I'll add a couple of things
from the searcher perspective first of
all what the structure allows you to do
as an entrepreneur it allows you to
focus on acquiring a company a much
larger company that I think at least I
personally was able to focus on coming
right out of business school and
certainly with with my own funds you
have a financial backer that allows you
to all of a sudden start looking at
companies that are you know above the 3
5 10 maybe even 20 or 25 or 30 million
dollar revenues whereas if you know you
don't forgive you don't have that
backing it's uh unless you have a lot of
money in the bank it's very hard to do
on your own and the second thing is
besides the the economic equation it
gives you as an entrepreneur the ability
to run a business and sometimes a fairly
sizable business
um when nobody else at least in my case
would have given me that opportunity at
least nobody in the right mind so so
from that perspective is uh it's it's
it's a phenomenal opportunity to get to
a level of running a potentially fairly
sizable business but the general
mechanics are as a search funder you're
raising a fund to fund you to pursue the
acquisition typically how many investors
do you have so the the typical
structures you raise a few hundred
thousand dollars to fund your operating
expenses for a period of generally two
years two to three years you divide that
in typically in units be between
investors that agree to come in and fund
your search with the so how many
investors typically what you do is you
have between 5 and 15 investors that
come in at the search stage and there's
the understanding that the investor has
the opportunity but not the obligation
to invest in an acquisition once you
create the opportunity so the two things
that the investor and this in the search
stage gets is number one the opportunity
to invest in an acquisition that you
find a number two there's typically an
economic incentive in the form of a
what's known as a step up the money that
they put in at the beginning buys them
more equity than the investors that come
in just at the acquisition stage so
there's a neck anomic incentive to to
participate in that stage I'll also say
for those of you not been to our website
the Center for entrepreneurial website
Center for not entrepreneurial studies
website has just a plethora of
information about search funds so if you
want old videos search run studies
sample acquisition
we have everything there so I encourage
you to go there if you want a lot more
information which referred to drinking
the kool-aid I think you're at the GSB
that the students and the faculty and
staff here think that sometimes the only
way to do an acquisition is by way a
search fund but rich and Michael do you
want to talk to why you decided to not
pursue a search phone I know Julie did
it right out of school and Michael a few
years later sure I did look at the
search phone model in our class we had
several people who had done it and in
the next room and so I spent a lot of
time actually talking to people about
the model and what it meant and what I
came down to was that I thought that 1i
I was going to target a specific
industry and all the people that all my
classmates they were doing search funds
were doing a more general search and I
so I thought targeting a specific
industry I could do it in less time I
was willing to sell fun for a year I
didn't need an income at the time or at
least my wife was willing to pitch in
and support me for a year and so it
wasn't a question of needing income and
since I was talking the specific
industry well I didn't raise a search
fund I did approach a couple of
investors who are in the industry and
said if I bring you the right deal
Willie back me and there was no
commitment to that but I felt that if I
brought them the right deal that they
would step up and help me out so I ended
up with two investors the other thing
was that my deal was smaller and you
mentioned search funds given you the
ability to go to larger companies I want
to do in the majority share my company
ended up with fifty five percent and
that was important to me in retrospect I
think it was overly important and i
might do things differently the second
time around but my deal aspirations were
smaller so i didn't need as much
financing that a search pond and the
access Capital they provide that they
would provide so for me I felt given all
those dynamics I could go out and spend
the time and find a company myself when
i graduated in 2002 i actually found my
first company
career colleges about one month after
graduation in the market that for true
prospect colleges subsequently found
private equity funding for mayfield
college i actually did not raise funds
so i had an opportunity to be the sole
investor which to me is a better fit for
what what I want to do when I want to
accomplish so it is a different it's a
different scenario having private equity
in one venture and doing it yourself a
second venture I think it gives you a
lot more freedom but I do think that you
know certainly straight out a business
school it is very hard to buy your own
business but certainly once you get on
the merry-go-round you know who your
second third or fourth time you do have
that opportunity to beat the sole
investor when sort of twist on mine was
that i actually purchased a turnaround
last year so typically search funds or
even unfunded searches focus on
profitable companies i bought a company
that was dying and turned it around so
it was it gave an opportunity for me to
be the sole investor in that weather
some elements of the search fund that
made it not appealing to you or was just
doing it on your own was high on was was
a paramount I wanted this I wanted to
have a hundred percent equity in the
venture it was very important to me now
Michael how did you find answer your
acquisition I ended up with my own money
to investors money and then a small
business loan sba loan great um
certainly I remember that as my husband
was going through this and talking to
other search funders it's a tight little
group the kind of the fear of coming
into purchasing a company and basically
you've signed your life up for the next
five to seven years you're getting on a
treadmill and you're not getting off I
don't know if that's considerably
different than other entrepreneurs who
start their own companies but how do you
guys kind of think about that and factor
that into your decision to make an
acquisition you know for me it was I
thought about this a lot and it wasn't
something I woke up in
one day and sounds like you guys came
around out of business school and when
to this model for me it started choosing
Stanford was in part because of its
reputation is having very
entrepreneurial students I knew that I
wasn't ready or at least I didn't have
the guts to go do it right out of
business school so but every decision
after that the types of jobs i chose
goodington to increasingly smaller
companies venture-backed companies was
all about ultimately wanting to be an
entrepreneur so by the time I did it it
wasn't it wasn't scary thing it was like
I prepared for decade to to do it you
had an industry focus so it wasn't a
random industry you were doing it no no
and and I hadn't been in that industry
but I I was I was I understood the
industry and so by the time I the time I
went to my wife and said I want to quit
this job making 150 year and and go do a
search for a year she was like well
that's nice take your coat it's cold
outside you know it was just sort of
this okay you know just go ahead and do
it and so it by the time i did it wasn't
scary you know retrospect I should have
been more scared and but you don't know
that until you do it and so for me it
was being prepared doing a lot of things
professionally educational leave that by
the time I went out and did it I was
confident I was comfortable and I just
kind of did it well I'll pitch in I from
my perspective you talk about making a
commitment for five to seven years my
the way I looked at it is I was making a
commitment to the process trying to
order the idea of doing something
slightly different from the on the
beaten path and pursuing the opportunity
to to run and build a business that was
kind of my central focus and that was
what I was making the commitment to I
I'm I was fairly indifferent or I guess
didn't really enter too much into my
thinking process am i committing to an
industry that i'm not going to enjoy or
or a company that i'm not going to enjoy
a thing from an industry perspective
certainly you have the opportunity to
focus your search and from a company
perspective at the end of the day you're
running the company so you have a lot of
power to shape that company i but i
think the commitment to the idea is is
what's really important to commitment to
the concept that you're gonna be for a
period of maybe two to three years
without knowing what's going to happen
next and to me that is that if i were to
give advice to people that are
considering doing this that would be the
kind of the key factor that i would
consider am i comfortable with investing
two years of my life into this process
which is fairly ambiguous and you just
don't know what's going to happen to it
really is a difficult thing to go
through and so to me it took several
months i started doing a self-funded
search and about six to nine months into
it i decided yes this is what i want to
do this is the path i'm going to take
and i just made the decision and ran
with it but certainly with the kind of
opportunity cost that we all have coming
out of business school where you might
have the opportunity go into a you know
private equity job or whatnot that may
be very economically rewarding it's a
tough decision to make you really have
to commit to the to the concept I'm rich
you've seen a number they always talk a
little bit register values something
that just a little bit of lemon most
people here are involved with the
business school or some business school
or another and there's there's a
tendency to think that we're
control we can manage our lives and
manage our careers and and the fact is
my partner night we found that the
people that end up doing a search fund
they've kind of subconsciously or maybe
consciously abandon that notion realize
that they can't help they just have to
do this they would have less control
over the planned career path that they
have and more control over the
day-to-day fabric of what they're doing
in their job they want to they want to
have more impact on the business they're
working on and they just have to do it
and if you if you grind on it too much
and think on it too much chances are
it's probably not right for it because
there's just a leap you got to take and
not not everybody can do that rich
having seen a number deals and we've
talked a little bit about the financial
structure of search funds but do you
want to talk about the financial
structure of the acquisition what tends
to be financed by debt versus equity yes
um when we started our fun now three
years ago we kind of envisioned that
over time the mix of businesses that we
would be invested in would be roughly 70
30 service businesses their kind of
asset light and manufacturing businesses
which are more traditional lbo
candidates it has not proven out the
case we have virtually no manufacturing
businesses I think that's a function of
one the obvious macroeconomics going on
and two there's something about the more
dramatic upside possibilities of service
industries that seems to attract search
funders as a result of that the
financing structures
or a lot more creative they run the
gamut from completely seller financed so
we were involved in a couple of deals
where the seller-provided fifty percent
of the financing necessary and equity
came in and provided the other half and
the sellers did that knowing that bank
financing just wasn't available there's
a couple of deals now there's three or
four national lenders that are getting
pretty comfortable with cash flow
lending and not a lot of them moist
essence deal is is one that has a good
cash flow lender and that's getting
closer to the old LVL model although
there's not that much in the way of
leverage of all assets and so Moyes the
field is pretty highly leveraged and
then we've got a couple of deals that
were so attractive and the bank's head
did it around an earlier deal so that
our searchers were kind of skittish
about dealing with them that we just
piled in and through eighty percent of
eighty percent equity of the deal
because we wanted to close it so badly
we figured that if we're right in the
deal pencil out the way we hope who'd be
able to refinance within a couple years
and then get some leverage the key is
you've got to be pretty nimble and
flexible and creative because financing
goes the whole spectrum which I'm
interesting your perspective what your
perceptions of the benefits for a
searcher using a search funder it's
using doing a search fund as opposed to
doing it independently and what value
you and other investors the Davis isn't
here to can add to the search funder as
they go through the process we work with
a couple of teas that are doing a
self-funded search so we're not
exclusively married to the search fund /
saying
but these guys are essentially doing a
search fun with their own money what we
are we shy away from is is people that
have a day job and then on the side try
to find a business because it really is
an all-encompassing search you have to
just look at hundreds of deals and you
have to be able to go down dark alleys
time and time again and spend dozens of
hours wooing a recalcitrant seller it's
just really time intensive very
emotional and it's also very lonely
particularly if you're a solo person
doing it so the value that we think we
add is one and it sounds trivial but we
don't think it is picking up the phone
by the second ring when they call just
looking for somebody to talk to because
if you're doing a search fund and you're
a single searcher your expenses are laws
here in some crappy office somewhere in
office park out in south san francisco
and your cold calling all day and if you
get a lot of rejection and you kind of
get worried that you're going to go down
some path it gets them off track so the
fact that we're kind of checking in with
them all the time it's helpful saves the
spouse of a search funder I appreciated
that feature yeah coming home to me all
the time yeah it's true the other thing
that we have value in and i think is
providing a network now that we've been
doing this full time for three years
we've done dozens of people that have
either done searches they were familiar
with or there's our current network of
active searchers and active managers we
actually host an annual meeting they're
all talking to each other swapping tips
swapping leads on investors swapping
leads on banks swapping leads on
recruiting there's a lot of value to
them
moving all the time and then lastly i
think i think we're helpful in helping
guys when they finally there's always a
decision searchers start approach this
problem of whether they want to pick an
industry and dive down and get to know
it a little bit and try to find a
business in the industry or whether they
do it opportunistically and look at
deals and then learn the industry once
they like a deal we're kind of helpful
in guiding them around the industry
question and that we've got experience
now with different industries and the
earmarks that those industries have and
may have contacts and industries and so
if somebody starts going down a path I
think it's helpful early on to give them
a read on what the investor appetite for
that industry may be because they may
think it's real attractive but it may
have a hard time later convincing
investors that they're right thank you
now those of you who searched either
with or without a search fund do you
want to talk a little bit about your
process did you do industry focus
geography focus Moises did you focus on
Iowa or did you just end up there how
and how you went about the process of
actually looking for a company to buy
well I'll start no I did not focus in
Iowa in fact I never even imagined that
would end up living in Iowa when I spoke
to the owner of this company he said
where the company was and I was trying
to find on google maps where the hell
this place was but yes I ended up I
ended up living in in just on the border
between Illinois and Iowa and the
Heartland if you will so my process I
like i said before i started with a with
a self-funded search which to me it
really meant a i wanted to kind of prove
to myself before i took other people's
money that that I could that I felt that
I could pull it off number one number
two I it just had
to go through the process of actually we
were talking about before making that
five to seven year commitment I really
wanted to make sure that I was ready and
I thought about it for a long time but
that that first process really helped me
kind of crystallized it and say yes this
is what I'm going to do in and and just
kind of plunge in so in terms of the
process I started with a self on the
search and I started and I talked to a
lot of search funders or prospective
search funders about this and this is my
perspective this will work for me I know
there's people that have done it
differently and they have been
successful so this is by no means I'm by
no means pontificating here but to me I
started doing a fairly focused
geographical search focused on Southern
California and I had relatively I
thought a good sense of industries that
I could be interested in from my time in
private equity and what I concluded at
the end of that self-funded search
period is that when you go into this you
have to make yourself as efficient as
possible number one and you have to give
yourself the most chances to actually
find and buy a good company and again
the conclusion that I reached is that by
focusing on a particular region and I
just wanted to live in Southern
California and I didn't want to live in
a place like Iowa and and I just came to
the conclusion that number one if you
look at opportunities if you like a
couple of industries and you count the
number of companies that are in Southern
California in that particular industry
and then you take that number and say
okay how many companies are there across
the nation there's going to be always an
order of magnitude difference and that
translates into odds of you being
successful so at the end of the day I
concluded I'm just cut i'm really not
giving myself a fair chance if i if i
say i'm going to buy a company in Los
Angeles
now Julia Michael both had industry
focuses did you have an industry focus
or how did you do your industry analysis
to determine what you wanted to begin so
I started again with a geographic search
fairly in opportunistic and then when I
raced my search fund I said I'm gonna go
nationwide and I focused fairly quickly
after that on three industries I talked
about efficiency the second piece of the
process on i'll be i'll try to be quick
here by focusing on an industry you can
become in my opinion a lot more
efficient at looking at deals because
you know an industry you get an
opportunity you look at it you already
know the industry you don't have to
spend a couple of days figuring out if
this is an industry that you want to be
in so you can evaluate a lot more deals
a lot more quickly and you can also kind
of get to know some of the key players
and and start developing relationships
and so on and support so i did change my
focus still to an industry focused
search and again the comet those two
things were from my standpoint just it
just changed the whole game now when she
went to an industry search how long did
it take you to find your company well so
i started let's see time on was january
i started my search i decided i wanted
to raise a search one in September so
that was nine months into it I closes
search fund the next April so that's
what seven months out raising the fun
the search fund yeah and then I actually
found the company a few months after I
closed a search phone because I've been
searching for that one so start when I
from the time I basically quit my job
till the day I closed my deal two years
Michael do you want time at your process
I suspect you were probably little more
geographically I was I was both industry
and geography
I for purposes of wanting to be close to
family my family my wife's family I was
only willing to look from San Jose to
the north bay and east bay and Peninsula
I wanted to live in Northern California
which I you know Gavin gone through what
I've gone through the last four years
running this company wouldn't have been
impossible to do without my family but
it would have been really difficult
without their support so I'm glad that
I'd end up doing that so I felt like to
do it because the focus i had so once i
decided the industry i was going after I
needed to go in and refine that because
I initially wanted to go to the more
service-based aspect of the industry but
found as you mentioned that financing
that would have been very difficult so I
ended up going on the manufacturing side
and was able to raise I think it was
about seventy percent of the financing
was debt and which I just never could
have done in the service side also there
were dynamics on the service side that
men once you bought that company you're
a lot of your sales could walk out of
the door with salespeople which is much
more difficult when you actually control
the assets and so anyway I needed to go
and still refine my search once I
decided on the industry and then after
that it's a lot of blocking and tackling
yeah you've gotta buy yourself a headset
and get a computer and you are on the
phone and you're dialing for dollars and
you have to create a profile the type of
company and and you talked about this
efficiency thing for me it was creating
that profile going out asking questions
refining the profile refining questions
and just getting better better at
sniffing out the right people and the
right deals you know as you kind of go
on you got to be willing to iterate make
mistakes and keep building through it
and then Julie heard this three years
ago I mean with what ultimately happened
was somebody told me gemellus who's here
today
I said you tell tell everyone you know
that you're trying by a company and
can't tell your dentist your doctor
lawyer tell everyone and she never know
where deals going to come from and my
mother-in-law sent me a newspaper
clipping of a company that was for sale
and so I thought you know that that's
sweet but you know I kind of have a
process of methodology and she wasn't
really uh so two weeks go by and we're
going up to the North Bay to visit my
mother in a lot of attack I better call
this company because she's gonna ask me
about it and darned if it wasn't the
company ended up buying so it's a really
a finder's fee yeah yeah I I didn't but
you know she was amazing she wanted her
daughter close to home as she got it and
her finder's fee is my two and a half
year old daughter who talking about that
family thing I mean she my wife is in
graduate school Skinner masters in
gerontology so my mother-in-law actually
went part-time so that she could take
care of my daughter while my wife is
commuting down to San Francisco all
those things are just so you know
amazing and such a part of what you end
up doing that you you you can't discount
them so for me part of my search and
part of deciding what I was going to do
this the geography thing for me was a
lot about family and and like I said I'm
so glad that you're worked out that way
I'm just curious on the SBA loan that
you got since your company has assets
did you have to send a personal
guarantee or is it kind of
collateralized against this yeah that
that's the dirty little secret I mean
everything i do requires a personal
guarantee you know
today and I was fortunate that one of
the investors that I had signed on has
quite a bit of property and so he ended
up having to put up a couple apartment
complexes in a top of house and I didn't
I didn't have any property at the time
so it probably wouldn't have gotten done
it since he's more and anybody who's got
more than twenty percent which he has
has to do the same personal guarantee
and that's also something i didn't
realize actually something he didn't
realize and by the time he realized that
it was too late which was good for me
because he's the one who had all the
property and so in addition to the
personal guarantee his so if his assets
got attached now fortunately about a
year and a half ago i was they're gonna
rewrite refinance the deal and and got
away from the SBA and when i refinanced
i was able to make get there was no
property specifically attached other
than I suppose ultimately since we have
personal guarantee they can come get it
but kind of hope they won't take my home
if things go south we actually did a
program on entrepreneurial debt last
week it's not up on our website yet but
it will be short living at SBA rep there
as well um Julie want to talk a little
bit about your process sure I when I I
started looking my last quarter at the
GSB in my second year at that time I was
a dual degree with the School of
Engineering so I naturally assumed that
I would buy a manufacturing company and
shortly after graduation you know when I
started going to different companies to
see if they would sell to it became very
clear that I was not going to be able to
buy a Mac manufacturing company but it
ended up turning out for the best
because somehow through that identifying
a for-profit school and just fell in
love with the sector and love the
students love the process love
everything and so now that I'm on my
second venture continued with the same
industry now would you on your first
tell you partner with the private equity
firm were they a source for deals for
you at all or how did you source your
deals no I I was the I was
the sole source so it was really more
about going to trade shows going to
conferences trying to meet as many
people as I could taking people about to
plunge taking people out for coffee and
it was really more of that personal
relationship that had that deal flow
coming through me and actually my
current venture was actually through
some of that same networking that you
know I started right after graduate
school what did you guys find most
difficult about the search process rich
mentioned the needing moral support from
wherever it might come I mean was that
most difficult part for you what did you
guys find falling in love with the deal
you know that cliche term is keeping
yourself from just convincing yourself
it's the right deal and since I didn't
have the search fund backing for me it
was more going to people who I trusted
and talking to them about it and
ultimately you know the most about it so
you have to make the decision but in
talking to different people it was good
that I had some people really pick apart
my arguments and and forced me to kind
of look at some of the uglier truths and
the deal ended up doing the the last
minute I showed it to someone who had
any experience and he said you know
you're overpaying you know you got to go
back and you got asked for for a
reduction to mount about ten percent
reduction and and and I just didn't want
to do it I just wanted this deal that
this was like you know six months in and
I wanted to happen and but you know
convinced myself I should do it and so I
went to the owner on a Friday and told
him you know hey sorry I you got to come
down on your price and that was on a
Friday I said the worst weekend I mean
because I wanted it so bad but I had you
know had to do this and fortunately came
back on Monday
retuning so so for me the hardest thing
was was just you know that that
commitment to the process as you
mentioned and not just doing the deal
for the sake of getting it done to me
the the hardest part is is during the
search process the the ambiguity of not
knowing what's going to happen and and
very importantly it is particularly I
think difficult for me being that i did
my cert the search on my own is the the
the times when you are pursuing a deal
you like the company you think it's the
right one you spend you know a month
negotiating or whatever you're getting
to the point where you're gonna sign a
letter of intent then you're already
envisioning yourself living there and
you've already scoped out the
neighborhood and all of a sudden the guy
calls and says you know what I changed
my mind or simply disappears and doesn't
call you um you know it's kind of like
going on these alleys that rich was
talking about you're starting to see the
light at the end of the tunnel the light
of the end the alley and you find a big
cement wall and you got to go back and
start all over again um that's ready
just to take a day off that's very tough
that is really very tough yeah Julie I
have to agree with Michael is just um
falling in love with the deal and you
know throughout this whole process
you're that you're the top salesperson
you're selling other people you're
selling yourself you're selling the
seller that this is the one and it's
very hard to separate sort of a rational
state of mind and how much how badly you
want this the turnaround that I that I
bought I could even tell I was becoming
delusional I mean there was some serious
compliance issues and just all these
problems and I would sort of rationalize
it oh I know it's not that bad and I can
fix that and you know you tend to lose
focus because you want it so badly and
that was one of the things that was very
difficult for me to was to really step
back and you know put a list of pros and
cons and was I really able to solve
these problems or
I just you know fully myself and think
just because I wanted the deal done that
I could do it later I've got a pretty
interesting story so I haven't done an
official search I've done a number of
endeavours over the years but as I
mentioned earlier we we host an annual
gathering of our entrepreneurs and we
generally layout this nice little we
think about the agenda and we'll talk
them about the search for maybe two
hours and then have lunch and then talk
about some challenges in the management
side the rest of the day and the last
two sessions we've had we've scheduled
less and less time to the search and
more to the ongoing management
challenges forget even the guys that
have been out of the search for years
all they want to talk about is the
search it's clearly one of the most
emotional things that they've ever
experienced and to just kind of have
group therapy talking about it is
serious value to do all the other
searchers are in the middle of it like
oh god it's not going to go away is it
it's a hard deal I remember once search
funder we were that at that one time and
I think one of the hardest parts at
least from our side of it from my side
equation watching my husband go through
it was everybody coming up saying he
found a company yet are you gonna get a
real job and one of these search funders
event came after he says I'm going to
sit here and talk to you because nobody
else understands what I'm doing that it
is it can't be very isolating I one of
the things I remember a lection day
every time I watch somebody who's won
the presidential election they turned to
my husband I said boys my own now crap
we got to do the job I mean you buy a
company show up the first day here are
all these people who've been working at
this company I mean how do you manage
that transition into running a company
how did the ploys react to frequently a
young person coming in to run a company
which probably was not run by a young
person before how's that transition look
I'll jump in so I you definitely need
you need to script it it's something
that I thought about a lot and turn
it's kind of what's my hundred day plan
you know what I bet it do and and and
script and orchestrate all your moves
down to you know interviewing talking
every single person visually on day one
figuring out who you want to pull aside
ahead so there was a couple of key
people sales people that I pulled aside
the day before before I went in there
and talked to every other you know every
other employee being younger I brought
in my one of my investors who while he's
only 10 years older than me he looks
about 20 and so I kind of brought him in
and said you know hey you know here's
one of my investors and while they won't
be here day to day the guy's got 20
years experience in this industry and
you know he's going to be around I tried
to keep the strategy talked to a minimum
you know it was more about what does
this mean to you as employees I didn't
go in there with a vision and try to
paint this Greg strand grand scheme it
was more about laying fears
uncertainties and doubts about what this
meant to them and why it was going to be
a good thing for them yeah and then you
then you said about dealing with all the
pent-up frustrations and stuff that's
been boiling in these companies that you
didn't know about and so you know you
want to spend you want to make sure that
you don't go in or at least for me it
was important not to go in there and
start trying to make radical changes go
really smart guy and was going to
revolution but go in and learn and and
kind of I had to absorb a lot of you
know frustrations and different ings
that were going on and and then kind of
like slowly picked my spots look for
quick wins before i started going in
there making wholesale changes so that
was my approach and it was it was less
about me and my youth and more about you
know okay here's the new guy and you
know let me see what he can do and here
i want to vent my frustrations and and
try to get something out of this
it sounds similar to the process I went
through although I I was fortunate that
in the process when I was negotiating
deal fairly soon after after I signed a
letter of intent with the owner I think
in their minds they kind of decided or
made the mental determination that they
had sold a company even you know while i
was doing diligence and you know did the
chameleon things could have happened and
the deal wouldn't have gone through but
in their minds that sold the company so
they actually opened the doors fairly
widely open and said and they started in
people at the company started treating
me as the new CEO very you know six
months before maybe four months before
the deal actually closed so i had a good
amount of time to actually get to know
people spend time with them do a little
bit of the you know reassuring that i'm
not going to try to come in here and
pretend i'm smarter than everybody and
make then change things around I was
very focused on explaining that first
and foremost I'm coming here to learn
the business and then build a good
platform so that we can grow the
business going forward I also brought
rich in fortunately he doesn't look 20
years old but it just yes certainly
knowing that there's a group of
investors behind me added to the to the
to the credibility and the credibility
thing is one that you know I've had to
work on for the last year I don't think
you know even though you come in as a
new CEO and everybody knows you're this
you're the president of the company you
have to earn that credibility no matter
what and that's what I've been working
on the past year and I think it's worked
fairly fairly well just radical change
of philosophy with the prior owners and
a lot of done a lot of things in the way
of
management style that that I think the
the people that are there were very good
but were never allowed to make any
decisions they actually appreciate the
change quite a bit Julie how was your
transition and when I first bought three
two career college right after business
school I was fortunate to have this
seller hire me to run the school so I
was able to be on site before the
transaction closed for about five months
and that was just ideal because I could
get that I could use that time to meet
people show them Who I am what I want to
do and then so when the transaction
actually closed it was a very peaceful
very smooth process with the turnaround
I actually had the total opposite where
as soon as we close I actually had to
fire the majority of the administrative
staff so I was not the popular person
and you know it was tough and so there
were things that I mean people didn't
like me for a long time and that's very
tough and you know how to do things like
you know which I still have to do today
which is you know I pay payroll every
week so you know payroll for you know
four times a month versus the first and
fifteenth which is you know that's not
fun but it was something that I had to
do to convince them that you know this
is this is a solid company and but you
know he i set the pattern very you know
early on and so it was it was tough stop
but she have any kind of best practices
or you know the lessons learned my car
tonight Julie's story I think sort of
symptomatic on the whole spectrum you
you may have as you're going through
your search or you're envisioning
running your company an ideal script
like Michael nation but reality is is
that it's going to take six months to
close sellers have different motivations
there's different circumstances you have
to be really creative there's there's
this mechanism that Julie talked about
on our first deal where you actually get
brought in earlier as a consultant and
sometimes doing the due diligence that's
sort of the beard that
kind of hide under because sellers often
don't want employees to know the
businesses for sale late because and so
they say yes we're bringing a consultant
in it's going to help us they're going
to help us look at the business to the
other end of the spectrum where it's
very abrupt and you have to change
things a lot of sellers you kind of want
to have them around for at least six
months for both their own transitional
reasons and because you want to make
sure there aren't some huge problems in
the due diligence we're missed and you
probably but I want to pay them for six
months and part of their compensation is
tied to sort of the company being as
represented so usually there's also a
little choppiness there where people are
going around you and go talk to the old
owner you got to make sure you watch
that another trick that you can
sometimes do we've had it happen success
with a couple times they're either
through your part of the transaction
price or the sellers good we'll have
some sort of an employee bonus that goes
back to the employees within the first
six months of the transaction is sort of
a please stay and you get paid extra
sort of thing and thank you from the
seller any kind of goodies that can go
to the employees early it makes our life
tangibly better makes the transition go
a lot smoother now it's here you guys
are all making these acquisitions and
going to add a tremendous amount of
value to the company and then sell it
and make your millions and retire where
are you what spend your strategy to add
value to your company's you obviously
had it turn around to deal with where
have you been trying to add value for
the companies and how are you doing it
our primary focus is actually on realist
so the profits from the school actually
fun real estate acquisition so it's you
know we don't envision a selling point
for the school for example I plan on
being 90 years old and still running
these schools so I don't see an exit
strategy and it's just really about
creating the right management team
creating a great morale culture you know
when you don't have an exit strategy
you're really building for the long term
and so you you do make these sacrifices
early on that maybe you wouldn't have
made if you had like a five year or
three year strategy so I it's just
really about loving what I do and just
trying to make my employees happy my
students happy trying to grow trying to
buy more real estate that's a beauty not
having investors you don't have to give
them a stern sorry rich its attention um
so so my strategy during the first year
for creating value is not destroying any
value first I've really taken the
approach that I certainly during the
first year I want to learn the business
and you know a couple of things that
that I've learned in the first year is
number one there's there's typically
some long heck that some low-hanging
fruit that you can come in and identify
and small changes here and there but
firstly when you come in to accompany
slowly in my case you just you don't
know what you don't know and there's a
lot of things that I've come to learn
this year that I just didn't have a clue
when I first bought the company even
after six months of due diligence even
after nine months of studying the
industry there's just a lot of things
that have tremendous amount of things
that I've learned this year that with
the information now and with the
knowledge and and that will only get
better over time you can certainly make
smart decisions and not waste a lot of
time I think it's dangerous to fool
yourself into thinking that you know you
have this MBA and you're going to come
in and you're going to make all these
great changes and
company is going to be amazing well
guess what you know people that were
there were probably just a smart if not
smarter and certainly street savvy so so
my strategy has been you know first come
in and learn the business figure it out
first before making any any big changes
the other thing is that i think
particularly in a small company there's
just so much change at a small company
can take and the particular the people
at a small company can take in a defined
period of time and I think you got to be
real careful about managing that so
people people that have been used to a
certain lifestyle mean I have employees
in my company that I've been there for
20 years and very little has changed and
all of a sudden you got all these things
going on it's it's dangerous you can you
can risk loosing a lot of very key
people a few if you try to do too much
too quickly Michael how long ago was
that you bought your company for years
okay yeah for years so to start it for
me and I guess background wise I how I
ended up in the commercial printing
industry is for three years I've been
vice president marketing for a company
that developed ecommerce software for
the print industry so in that role I
literally went in you know at all the
trade industry trade shows and I visited
hundreds of printers and so by the time
I started my search I had a an idea of
why looks i thought i knew why they
didn't do as well as they could do and
again you know not knowing what you
don't know is always the big surprise
and so my strategy was by good company
that was solid operationally but you
know get the value by growing the top
line and so with that that allowed me to
not grow it up and sell it but like
Julie you know my hope is that I'll grow
it large enough throw often
cash that I can increasingly add more
professional management and my role
becomes less stable day as it is today
but you know I I can take off for a
month and the company runs itself and I
go vacation and I come back and I still
get to participate in strategy the
company so Mike Michael at the end of it
is is not to sell it but how generate
enough cash to support my lifestyle and
so you know as four years ago about the
company I've grown revenue fifty percent
that's allowed me to root out some weak
players bring in a sort of a middle
management layer of professional
management I'm not there yet i'm still
doing the 12 hour days and every
saturday morning till noon or one but i
see the path that if i keep if i have
another year next year like I had no 6
in the year after that I'll creasing Lee
be able to get myself to the size where
I can start to back out and just do the
things i want to do with the company
because i think i would be bored if I if
I didn't have I think this is the kind
of thing that I can I don't say play
with but you know this this will be my
project and so if i get to the point
where we're generating of cash where i
can all be involved strategically and go
and see the top clients that would be a
great lifestyle for me and so when i get
to the point where it just runs by
itself if I don't show up then I'll
consider it a success everyone's go
ahead place it one of the things we like
about the search fund model is that to
us it is a great indicator of the
persuasiveness and na salesmanship
entrepreneur the notion of a search fund
in and of itself is kind of preposterous
I want you to invest in me I don't know
what I'm going to do with the money
believe me I'll work hard for it if you
can pull that off convince 12 people to
do that you you're a natural salesman if
you can convince a seller that you have
the money behind you and the moxie and
the ability to to sell to pull off the
transaction you're a good salesperson
it's a bank or some other investors that
you're worth the risk you a good
salesperson inevitably in our mind where
most of the value can be added in small
businesses is on the sales and marketing
side it's entirely rational for a very
smart guy who's been running a business
for 20 beers once he gets to pull in a
million dollars a year out of the
business his lifestyle like Michael said
it's not all that great a calculation
for him to now reinvest the new products
or new sales initiatives or to hire an
asst sales people because he's got his
life exactly where he wants it and so
like we like I mentioned if yours
innately a sales person and you're
running a small business you're going to
end up spending a lot of your time on
the sales side and that you can usually
find a way of making a nice jump in your
business by concentrating on the sales
and marketing side first question is why
not start a business why is this more
attractive than starting a business we
talked about comparing the two models
and then how do you make the economics
of a service business start for me it
was timing in 2002 when I decided to
search for a company I thought initially
I would start a company but in 2002 if
you guys think back things were pretty
tough out there and valuations had
really come down and I felt I could buy
a company and get a higher return sooner
by doing what I did which is by coming
it operationally but lacked the sales
and marketing savvy and that would be
more successful than trying to come up
with some great new idea and start a
company and get
stairs and employees area so for me it
was timing I wouldn't have done that
even two or three years earlier where
valuations were crazy even for small
private companies say it's really there
in that time frame we didn't see that my
search fund starting in 99 2000 what
about the service business that's your
honor um to both of those questions what
strikes us is the fact that you've got
an ongoing cash flow to leverage both
operationally and financially if you've
got a service business that already has
customers and you can do your due
diligence and kind of confirm that it's
not a commodity that the switching costs
are relatively high we think that you've
kind of mitigated a lot of the risks of
giving money and power to a younger
entrepreneur that might might not be
able to handle all the variety of issues
that come with a start-up so the search
fund kind of in our mind gives you a lot
of the upside a lot less of a downside
to start up and the service component of
it you really got to check on the due
diligence and make sure it's it's not a
straight commodity service because if
you've got customers and you're
providing service for them it's they
don't want to switch I think the
question pertains to getting desperate
at the end it is it necessary to have a
two-year runway or can you get desperate
at six months well talk about from my
perspective I think if you look at the
structure there's definitely in a
built-in incentive to do a deal to do
something whether you know and frankly a
lot of it is serendipity when first of
all how quickly can you get up to speed
on the industry that you're convinced
you want to be in but more importantly
you know within those two years there's
a there's a component of love the way
you when you find you know the right
company in the right industry with the
right guy
I that is ready to sell at a relatively
rational price again talking about it
from my experience looking back at a lot
of the deals that i had early on i'm at
the time they probably look like really
good deals and i really wanted to do
them but i'm so glad i did not do them
and I think there's certainly that
learning curve the beginning of just
looking at a bunch of stuff now how much
runway did you have after you made your
acquisition uh well I so I closed my
fund in April and I found the guy I
found like I said I found the company
fairly quickly and i bought the company
in january so that was a period of eight
he still had another I still heard by
rebuilding that could have runway yeah
but part of the reason why I decided to
raise a search fund was because I wanted
to avoid getting desperate I mean I was
basically doing a self-funded search and
when you do herself on the search you
see your bank account going down every
month and I didn't want to be in the
situation where i just had to do any
deal because of that exact negative
incentive and so I said let me raise the
search fun and get myself the right not
a time I have to adding points that one
of the places where we feel that we can
add value as investors in the search
that really know the whole search
process is that at 18 months if we
really like the entrepreneurs and we
feel that their potential is great and
we get a sense they're starting to feel
the collar a little bit and getting a
little intense and overly anxious you
know we like to talk to them and say
look you're doing great work you're
going to find a business in if you run
out of money it's not going to be that
hard to keep looking and we will
fun and so that that drop-dead date kind
of recedes a little bit in their
question was give some substance and
some numbers around the range on the
size of search funds and given that
there's so much cash in the market right
now is that affecting the ability to
make acquisitions and great questions as
a rule of thumb the budget number that
searchers are talking about these days
is trying to give yourself a 30-month
runway two and a half years and at a
salary of 80 grand a year with attendant
due diligence expenses and such that
usually pencils out between 250 and 300
grand for a single entrepreneur and 550
on the whole usually for two guys going
into the second question that's a nice
segue is that there's a school of
thought about in the search phone world
about single guys versus two-person
teams the two-person teams are much
better at finding deals that just two
heads equal three sets of eyes I mean
it's just they are more prodigious
attorney up deals single guys it's
harder there's just not as much
bandwidth on the other side single guys
are more likely to find a deal that's in
a sweet spot of the old traditional
search fund which is below the radar
they can work the economics out so that
they can see at the end they can
envision making their five to ten
million dollars if everything goes right
and they can buy a five-million-dollar
business if you've got two people they
start looking up in the 15 million
dollar revenue range and now all of a
sudden in the last
years they're pushing up against the
private equity money which is surging
down and so it is it is a problem that
with particularly with two person teams
that are ambitious and have raised 550
grand so now they're step up I mean
that's a big number all of a sudden if
you multiply that times 1.5 you plug in
800 grand a fan of equity into a deal
you need to hit a pretty big homer to
make it sing for both of the two guys
and so we have had issues where sorry
guys this is a good-looking business but
we cannot bid against some private
equity shop that's got 150 million under
under management and they're willing to
pay seven times even though it just
isn't going to work so there's that's
where we have to show discipline we have
to signal that to them pretty quickly
because they we can't get into auctions
with those guys time for one more
question at the wall at the GSB i did a
390 and looked at 12 industries actually
with Chuck Holloway which was very
helpful in terms of really analyzing a
sector or an industry and just going
through it systematically also during
that time I called investors tried to
set up meeting some I was successful
with some not spent a lot of time CES
Linda in particular has was just
tremendously enormously helpful just
really tried to learn as much as like I
could speak with former search funders
because while I was at the GSB I thought
I was going to do a search fund and what
I found that the network of search
funders is just wonderful they always
return your calls they always take the
time to speak with you and really
provide good contacts and deal flow and
it was something that actually took me
by surprise how
snit of that network is and then
graduation just came quickly and then
you're sort of on your own what is here
about a year uh I was actually out a
year and a half before I started so that
while you were at school you weren't
doing anything in particular no I
thought about doing a search fund in my
particular case I I didn't feel I feel
like I wanted to go back into the
business were a little bit after two
years of basking in the Sun and doing
all the great things that I would
business school yeah that's what I hear
um I'm glad I'm out so so just again I I
kind of thought about the idea but
wanted to get back into the business
while went back into private equity and
that that experience in my case was just
very helpful in terms of knowing what to
look for in a company analyzing deals
know how to talk to brokers and dead
sources equity investors etc and you
guys have anything at last where's the
wisdom before we dismiss lodges echo it
Julie seconds this came up a lot more in
the last panel but the the Alumni
resources are great i mean by that i
mean the stupid former students going
through it if everyone took my call
everyone did lunch with me and just you
know it was amazing how much I learned
just by talking to just so many people
have every meeting every phone call I
learned at least one thing that I could
use and so use that resource one last
thing is if you're thinking about doing
something like this and for some reason
you don't think you're quite ready I
really recommend that you talk to us you
talk to other people that are running
businesses one of the biggest
bottlenecks then our businesses have is
telling and you can learn an awful lot
about whether this really is the right
world for you if you go to work for a
small business for a year or two and
they'll put you in key roles give you
all kinds of great responsibilities it's
it's one way of kind of bridging that
doubt gap if you have yeah be willing to
move to Bettendorf Iowa I guess I've got
a portfolio of deals all companies from
Honolulu to Charlotte nobody has asked
about more hey I had a great with Doug
Anaya was one of the ones that was X
down on our list so how are you for
going so thank you all of you for coming
hope you enjoy the day